the miss malotte humming la Salam
alaikum peace be unto you welcome back
to the Deen show every week we're here
trying to help you understand the most
misunderstood way of life in the world
yet it's the fastest growing way of life
in the world and more women are coming
to Islam than men
Islam is amazing and we're gonna be
talking about it it's the way of life of
all the messengers of God but how do I
know it's the truth
there's a book out there you can get it
for free it's called the Qurans the
verbatim word of god it's a living
miracle we attest to the miracles that
Jesus did that Moses did but how do you
verify these things today the Quran
posts a challenge if you believe if you
feel it's from other than the creator of
the heavens and earth to one God go
ahead find one discrepancy there's so
many miracles in the Quran and we're
going to be discussing one of those here
today with dr. Lawrence Brown when we
come back sit tight don't go nowhere the
one who created you that he's one and
alone running this universe that he
doesn't become it doesn't make sense who
was Jesus worshiping this is recorded in
the gospel despite all of the other
issues about the gospel you put those
aside with the Saints mentioned there
with Jesus
greetings a peace Salam alaykoum how are
you well it cuz I was little I dr. Brown
dr. Brown
time is short and we want to get right
into the topic people can go to the Dean
show calm to read a little bit about you
we've done several shows with you in the
past and I really get excited working
with you not only I you and my brother
you're a good friend and thank you for
joining us here my pleasure
yeah so we're gonna be talking about the
verbatim Word of God the Quran now we
could talk on this for days but we just
want to kind of give people a taste just
kind of give people you know a better
understanding because we say it's the
verbatim Word of God there's no other
book like it it tells you what the
purpose of life is where you're going
when you die it has so many things in
there that anyone would open heart and
open mind after they read it after they
look into it they'd conclude like over
1.5 billion people that there's no way
that this book could have come from a
human being or a devil but from the one
god that created the same creator of
jesus moses abraham and all the
messengers of god so in this short
amount of time we just like to to talk
about you know the quran do you think we
can do this sounds good to me so tell us
what what you know we can espouse on
many of the scientific miracles we can
expose on how it's been memorized by
millions like no other book what do you
feel is a very important point and and
and something as would just have the
light bulb come on if people reflect
over it you know oh gosh i mean there
are so many of those yeah as you just
mentioned there are many lines of
evidence okay in in my book got it i
basically address the innate appeal of
the quran the miracle of the language of
the Quran how the Quran relates to
previous events contemporaneous events
future events and then how it relates to
the unknown scientific miracles that
there was no possible way anybody in the
world could have known those things not
only during the time
of Muhammad peace be upon him book for a
thousand years after but things which
are accurately described in the Quran
which we now know as scientific fact so
there there are many many many lines of
evidence I mean I don't think there's
any way to say one is more stunning than
the other but I think that I think one
way of looking at it is this our
creators sent every prophet to make an
impact on the people with his message
okay
and in order to do that he gave the
prophets a gift he gave them something
unique that made them stand out to the
people that they were preaching to okay
so for example Moses sent to Pharaoh and
the Egyptians in that culture in that
time the the thing that the people
revered more than anything else was
magic sorcery yes basically you know
Pharaoh was surrounded by his own
magicians his own sorcerers and every
town had you know the sorcerers he'd go
to for this or for that that was the big
thing of their age and so it is not
surprising to find that the signs that
our Creator gave to him to Moses were
the signs impressive to the people of
that time where the feats of we can't
say magic but the miraculous feats that
he performed you know the staff turning
into this serpent and things like this
defeated the sorcery of Pharaoh's court
sorcerers
now this was a message to the people to
show that this man was sent by our
Creator in the same way Jesus Christ was
sent to a population of people and in
their culture and their time the
greatest thing the greatest skill a
person could have was the skill of
healing okay and as we know I mean he
healed the lepers he cured the blind he
raised the dead all by the will of allah
we believe all of this
we believe as Muslims we believe all of
this but we believe that Jesus Christ
did this as he said he did it by the
will of Allah not that he was doing it
by himself as he said I of myself can do
nothing so that's the difference
Christians believe these miracles we
believe these miracles okay but
Christians put a different spin on the
miracles yes and they allow in their
minds these miracles to elevate Jesus
Christ we continue to believe in Jesus
Christ as the man and the Prophet that
he himself said he was but just to go
back to the point so you know where as
Moses presented to his people with this
unique attribute of miracles beyond what
they could perform Jesus Christ was
presented to his target population so to
speak with an ability that surpassed
that of any other human being the
ability to heal now the Arabs the Arabs
were the population to whom the
revelation of the Holy Quran came first
right revealed through the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him what was the
skill that they revered more than
anything else it was language you know
that the eloquence and the impact of
language so many scholars say that the
greatest miracle of the Quran is not the
scientific miracles it's not the it's
not the fact that the Quran corrected
misconceptions about the past not the
fact that the Quran spoke of events of
the present in a way that could not
could not have been done except through
divine knowledge not the fact that the
Quran spoke of future events that would
take place with with accuracy again
something that could not be done except
by the will of Allah but none of these
things the greatest miracle of the Quran
was the language the language the
language I mean I mean think of this the
Quran is revealed in ten readings in
seven different dialogues and dialects
ten readings seven different dialects
now we have to understand
how the quran was revealed we have to
understand the eloquence of the language
and when you put the entire package
together which is very difficult to talk
about just as we're talking now but we
can touch on it when you put the entire
package together you just come to
realize that this is not something that
could have been constructed by human
mind that's let's can you hold your
point there and we're going to just take
a break we'll be right back with more
Muslim is a tenant our faith to believe
in and love Jesus Christ why is it then
when it comes to one of the most
important decisions in life he literally
abused ourselves it's not that the main
thing we're looking for is to see what
type of money he has so that he can
treat my daughter like a princess back
here on the Deen show we're talking to
dr. Lawrence Brown we're talking about
the verbatim Word of God the Quran
please continue on where you left off
okay my head is kind of swimming because
I almost don't know where to start but I
mean let's just begin by saying that you
know the desert Arabs the better ones
were I mean they were tough people and
yet they prized language so much that
they would have contests they would have
contests on poetry contests to you know
to show who is the most eloquent and
there were huge prizes given to those
who were honored as as the winner of
these contests and yet when the Quran
was revealed that subjugated the Arabs
in their own language what do I mean by
that I mean for example a law challenged
mankind in the revelation to produce
another Quran like it you know just
basically saying if this is not from God
produce one like it nobody could
so Allah lowered the bar and made it
easier
and in another revelation later in the
Quran Allah challenged the people not to
produce an entire you know Quran but
just to produce 10 surahs like it again
when the greatest poets the greatest you
know the greatest artisans of the
language of that time could not do this
Allah lowered it again to the point
where he challenged mankind to produce
just one sort of one sort of like that
of the Quran know the shortest sorta in
the Quran is ten words ten ten words
hello hello was challenging mankind from
that time until this to produce
something like it only ten words long
and nobody has ever been able to do that
now what does that mean you know what
does that mean what for you know we know
the Quran is in Arabic you know was that
open to anybody in the Persian language
language to this day or does that mean
in Arabic and what does that mean can
you elaborate on this a little more it's
a challenge to mankind to all of mankind
not just to one person I mean you'd get
your friends together and sit around and
try to come up with a 10 word you know
saying that that exceeds the Quran in
eloquence and impact and meaning mm-hmm
it's never happened no never in 1400
years now you have to understand a few
things first of all Muhammad peace be
upon him was illiterate he could not
read he could not write this is a
historic fact oh this is historic fact
non-muslims attest to this yeah so this
is well known so to begin with the the
whole scenario just sounds unbelievable
that the greatest work of eloquence was
revealed through a man who was a little
illiterate to begin with
boy I was almost becoming you know
illiterate there but you know it's
almost unbelievable just on the face of
it but then you know in addition we have
to we have to keep in mind
it just doesn't make human sense I mean
the disbelievers say that that Muhammad
spoke from his own mind right look the
greatest artisans in all time see the
mistakes in their work better than
anybody else
Michelangelo would never have said he
would never have challenged anybody else
to carve a greater statue I mean he was
his own greatest critic the reason why
you find a lot of Michelangelo's Statue
statues with arms broken off legs broken
office because there was a period of
time when he once went into his workroom
and he smashed his own statues with his
own hammer okay you would never expect
Beethoven's or Mozart to challenge
somebody to write better music you would
never expect Rembrandt or any of the
great painters to challenge somebody to
paint a greater painting why because
throughout time artisans even the
highest even the most accomplished
artisans always saw the fallacies in
their work better than anybody else okay
it is not it is not a human
characteristic to challenge other people
to outdo you when you know that you can
be outdone mm-hmm so it it you know for
for this challenge to be had to have
been made in the first place could only
have been a challenge made by God no man
would ever been so foolish as to say
write ten words better than mine and you
will disprove that this is revelation no
man would ever say that it would be
craziness mm-hmm yeah and what would
this be I mean really the people at that
time you know who are masters of the
Arabic language they really even more
sauce that many people who don't know
the Arabic they even appreciate this
more you know even in the time of
Muhammad peace be upon him the
disbelievers those who those who refuse
the message they would still at night
when it was dark they would still sneak
to where they could hear the Quran being
recited to listen to it because of its
beauty and because of its impact there
was a famous story where
three of the greatest antagonists to
Muhammad three of the greatest enemies
to Islam bumped into one another at
night coming home from one of the Quran
recital yes and they they caught one of
one another at it and you know basically
said what are you doing no well okay
yeah well I was there so they agreed not
to do it again the next night in the
dark of night the the Quran recital
finished they bumped into one another
again in the dark this time they swore
by their gods never to come back and the
next night they bumped into one another
again that is how powerful the impact of
the Quran was upon the Arabs who
understood its message even though they
were disbelievers even though they were
opposing the message they were so drawn
by it that they would sneak out at night
to listen to it even when they had been
you know previously caught two nights in
a row amazing yeah
before we go to a break I mean we see a
lot of people you're an author yourself
and you know many people they write and
before in their introduction of preface
you know they're apologizing for the
mistakes that you know they might have
made or you'll see you know the next
book to that one coming up you know
modifications at it's revisions but
isn't it true that in the Quran you know
the second chapter
many people have accepted Islam just
because you know the boldness says this
is a book where there is no doubt in it
no yes is this true vali Kalka tabular
lie Buffy yeah I mean where is the book
in which there is no doubt to the best
of my ability to to translate the
meaning so it starts off telling you
there's no doubt in this book that is a
very bold statement exactly and and
you're right many people have come to
Islam because they have simply
recognized no human being would ever
have said that amazing I mean would it
would be too easily disproven if it were
human were
definitely we're gonna we're gonna get
into some more here on the D show with
dr. Lawrence Brown talking about the
verbatim Word of God the Quran sit tight
we'll be right back
everything this cup is in some serious
omission to the one who primitive
because it's following the rules of
gravity by definition this is how we can
say that Islam has been here since the
very beginning of time anywhere the
Muslims went to people embrace Islam in
massive countries nations and this is
something that is amazing never happen
on the face of Earth when people saw a
practical way of life of being truthful
to be honest making sense of everything
that they do they worship and they buy
into it back here on the Deen show with
dr. Laura's brows so much to talk about
this is a vast topic we're just touching
about little details here and there you
mentioned the prophecies that are in
there you know the scientific facts the
human development of the embryo
scientific I mean facts that are
confirmed not theories and tell us
there's a so many points just touch upon
this is it true that look the Quran has
been memorized by millions of people all
over the world and if you were to take
all the religious scriptures and if you
were to burn on thrown to ocean get rid
of them there is no other religious
scripture that you would be able to
bring back the way you'd be able to
bring back the Quran because of this
memorization by children that are the
age of seven eight
memorizing the whole book that's in the
hearts of the people and you made a
story about some Emperor's some king
that was doing this and then a child
came and said you can't get rid of the
kindness in our hearts it's in my heart
yeah you're right
and this is something again this is
challenge made to Islam people say that
no the Quran has been changed but no it
hasn't the Quran was always maintained
in the minds of the believers and and
there's a this beautiful word half
a--the half if Quran Haffa the Quran for
memorizer of Quran but half actually
means protector protector of the Quran
in the time of Muhammad peace be upon
him there were thousands there were
thousands who memorized the Quran from
the beginning to the end
so when whenever and
buddy made a mistake in recitation in
prayer or just you know in reciting
there was always somebody there to to
correct okay when the Quran was
committed to the Musa to the book when
it was written down during the time of
Abu Bakr and Othman and we still have
two copies okay the of these originals
one in Tashkent and one in Istanbul so
to these to the to this day to this day
the the believers have always protected
the message by memorizing it here more
than on paper on paper it's easy easy to
make a slip of the pen it's easy to
you're tired and and and you misspell
something or something but the the
believers in the beginning there were
the thousands
after that they became the millions you
know now now we have tens of millions
tens of millions of Muslims who have
memorized the Quran from the beginning
to the end and you know any any error in
the in the Quran that they can identify
it instantly and correct it amazing
amazing I mean is it also true on every
page of the Quran the verbatim Word of
God God's name or his attributes are
mentioned over and over every page of
the book and also is this true and is it
true that if you look at it with us and
see open heart over mind there's nothing
that they called you to but good being
good doing good you know the message of
the Quran if you can expose on us in the
last few minutes you know some people
might say it's from the devil so many
points I want you to cover it show a
little time that someone says it's from
the devil every time we recite the crown
that has the name of God on every page
we seek refuge from the devil exactly
for God to protect us from the crown so
these three points is it true every
God's name is mentioned on every page
that we seek refuge from the devil when
we recite this qur'an and that
everything the quran calls us to is
nothing but goodness I mean I I can't
really add anything to that okay the one
thing I'll add the one thing that'll
that'll add is you said that some
Christians say oh this is from the Satan
but as you said within the Quran itself
the Quran tells us that to seek refuge
in Allah our
creator from satan the cursed one and
you know Christians Christians quote
from the Bible where it said where Jesus
Christ is recorded as having said that a
house divided against itself cannot
stand so if Satan cast out Satan he is
divided against himself okay
if Satan casts out Satan well here we
have the Quran telling us to seek refuge
in God from Satan okay so if the Quran
is from Satan and Satan is casting out
Satan all right so that that's simply
not possible that that's an impossible
formula common sense but also according
to the scripture of the Bible all right
so it's very clear that you know that
can only be from God this is amazing
amazing we're out of time if people want
to get ahold of you read some of your
books where can they get in touch with
you at okay the subject we're talking
about now is from my book got it you can
find all of my books on my websites
level truth com just two words no spaces
no underscores no hyphens just level
truth com
and you can also find eight scroll com
an action/adventure I've written eight
scroll down thank you very much once
again
they got Almighty Allah reward you for
being with us thank you thank you and
that was dr. Lawrence Brown on the Deen
show we just touched upon this very
important topic verbatim word of god if
somebody wrote you a letter
if you were really wanted to know who
your father and mother was and there was
a book out there describing them you'd
run to that book there's no other book
like it you buy all the books from
Barnes a normal Amazon what about the
verbatim of God we're telling you is
from the creator of the heavens and
earth and you can get it for free call
the number on the screen 1 800 662 Islam
why wouldn't you just pick it up why
wouldn't you just read it it teaches you
to be good it teaches you to be kind it
doesn't teach you to kill innocent men
women and children
it doesn't tell you the opposite to be
just to speak a just word to do
everything that helps you to develop
yourself to be the best human being that
you can be and the foundation is built
on check
south on pure monotheism worshiping only
one God not three in one four one five
one not a man or a monkey not a woman
but the creator of everything in this
universe is built on that and it's
something logical rational and it has
all the testable evidence but you've got
to give it a shot you give everything
else a shot give this a shot and tune in
every week to the Dean show until next
time peace be unto you
it's a way of life or to us man the
messenger best of me show us the way to
Allah's grace this is the Dean Dean
Addison this is the Dean Dean of his
you